so the first thing I wanted to ask you
is in your own opinion why do we need
another jungle book movie and what's the
value of adapting remaking rebooting and
all of that well let me just start by
saying when I came on board this project
in 2013 there was no other version in
the offing so so when I read it was a
very very fresh take I mean I was great
I grew up there 67 animation as you know
we all did and loved it and was inspired
by it and you know fell in love the
characters etc but when I read this
script that was very much about Mowgli's
journey and then and that and realized
that it was so closely associated with
the source material with the book you
know that was written in 1895 that I
found you know it was intoxicating and
and thought you know how many times do
we see a version of you know a play like
Hamlet you know there are
interpretations and one actor completely
different by another if the material is
there it's a classic piece of literature
it really can bear returning and it's
interesting that a lot of people still
don't even realize that it was it's a
book and it wasn't originated as you
know the 1967 animation so so I was I
was fairly confident that this could
come to life and and really examine the
journey of Mowgli which is why we have
called it Mowgli finally it's about it's
a very emotional visceral journey of
this you know of this young child seat
seeing how he fits into an ever-changing
world another thing I was dying to ask
you about is this whole idea of virtual
production because it's a term that
we're hearing more and more lately and
every time I'm talking about it on one
of our shows I feel kind of ill-informed
in terms of the definition and then also
weighing in on that argument of is it
live-action or is it animation so how
would you define it and where does it
fall in your eyes
well virtual production is is a way of
you know you you can using a virtual
camera and the CG world you can
basically plot out the entire movie it's
the same as old-fashioned storyboards
but you're doing it with a moving camera
with with previous pre-visualization
with carrot in our animated versions of
characters so that's that and then and
then you can actually take those shots
all the way through to you know final
some of them live and continue to go
through to final rendering and becoming
you know become in the movie but with
this this film we did use virtual
production but but actually we shot on
live locations so we actually shot real
sets we recreated real jungle sets at
least in the studio we didn't want a
kind of CG environment world fit for
this it wanted to feel visceral and real
and tangible I wanted to be able to
smell the jungle and the bugs that were
in it you know and then we shot a
location in South Africa just south of
Durban of course we were using
performance capture technology to create
the the the animals and that was because
because in order to make the journey of
Mowgli real and him and emotionally
engaging you have to have the other
actors there present on set and the
great actors that we had you know
turning in his extraordinary performance
is not least Christian Bale is Bagheera
you know Benedict Cumberbatch's Shere
Khan and cape Archer as cars make you
know though they were there on the set
acting with Mowgli and totally you know
just just the electricity between these
performers was just magnificent and then
you know and then of course you take
that through but it's their performances
that are there which are then the
animators take of course and then
translate the performance into the
creatures that you see
[Music]
you